article comes out talking about
what china is working on okay and when
you
when you go through this it's pretty
epic on what he explains
i sent you two links kai for you to pull
up okay before you guys pull this up
i'm going to ask you before you guys see
this here i want to ask you
what do you think is the biggest enemy
to us
the next five to 10 years what country
is the number one enemy to us in the
next five to ten years what do you think
do you think it's china do you also
agree with that i think we're our own
worst enemy number one but then as far
as a foreign enemy it's china okay who's
after china
who's after china as far as defense or
far as competition as far as give me any
of it give me any of it
russia's up there russia's up there for
what defense or economy
no uh defense defense russia outside of
north korea just because of the psycho
okay so recklessness is where you put up
there okay
so where do you think russia ranks
in world economy gdp once not not in the
top 50.
maybe maybe not maybe not in the top 20.
not the top 20s
what do you think russia right nine
they're number 11. russia's number 11.
okay
do you have the link i sent you kai okay
go to that one right there go to that
one right there watch this here
so this is the top gdps worldwide okay
this is from investopedia so it's not
just any
opinion u.s is number one at us nominal
gdp is 2.21.44
trillion and the gdp is the same right
but look at china where china's at next
their gdp is 27.31
trillion dollars coming up china's
experiences
experienced exponential growth over the
past few decades breaking the barriers
of a century
planned closed economy to evolve into a
manufacturing exporting hub of the world
china is often referred to as the world
worlds factory given its huge
manufacturing
and they're projected to get there you
know the way the numbers are going right
now to pass
up u.s in the next handful of years okay
they've already passed up in
gdp not nominal nominal gdp us's ahead
and then go to number three then you got
japan
then you got germany keep going down
then you got india
who's coming up aggressively then you
got uk then you got france
then you have italy then you have brazil
and then you have canada you do not see
what russia on the top down russia's
number
10 4.21 number four point two one
trillion canada is ahead it's
unbelievable that's unbelievable
california's way ahead
that's the point canada is ahead of
russia if you would have said that to
somebody they would say what are you
talking about
now watch with china do you know who has
the largest navy in the world right now
china do who has the largest army in the
world right now
china do you know what china is doing
right now with their military with their
soldiers
they're putting jeans they're putting uh
uh what do you call it
uh they're they're testing their
soldiers to become super soldiers
china's doing that so not just steroids
not just steroids they're testing their
soldiers they're putting additional
stuff into their soldiers
for them to become it's like gene
testing they're doing with their
soldiers for their soldiers to become
super soldiers
china's doing this now watch what
happens
yesterday tucker does a show talking
about a video that went viral
that was given by a professor of china
and he's given a message in china he's
given this message in china
china immediately take this video down
but before they take the video down
u.s gets a hold of it and they translate
what the speaker had to say
first of all pull up pull up the speaker
pull up the video of his
let me first explain who he is go back
to
uh uh introducing who he is so what is
that 9 13
go all the way to the beginning go all
the way to the beginning
here's who he is don shank
is the vice dean of the school of
international relations
redmond university of china vice
director and secretary of the center for
foreign strategic studies of china
this talk was given what um maybe
a week and a half ago okay say 10 days
ago can you go to the part that you want
to say and maybe
first put the speed at 1.25 because he
talks a little bit slow
okay then keep it at 1.0 just stay with
me here and try to read below because
he's not speaking in english
adam try to stay here on the bottom if
you guys want i can read it for you
but we'll go through this here together
look what he says matter of fact i want
to read it so everybody can see it
you can put it on the audio that's fine
hey i just an um this guy
by the way he's becoming the next thai
lopez of media every every time you
watch
something he comes up okay just try to
read it because it's tough if i read it
in
go back a little bit kai did you put it
on 1.0 what speed do you have it on
leave it at 1.0 no no one it's too much
go
okay go ahead
and support
are you kidding me are they doing this
many commercials nowadays on youtube
go back this is not a joke go back pause
it real quick okay this is the one thing
i don't want to i don't want to joke
about on this podcast
it's very very important this part you
guys have to pay attention to what he's
saying
okay but now we're seeing biden was
elected
just read the captions
the traditional lead the political elite
the establishment
has some sort of global foundation have
you noticed that who helped him
hunter biden build the foundations
are all these deals and all this okay
pause right there so positive time
who's he talking about got it who's he
talking about dad
he says no no this is china this is tama
china we did
we helped them okay so watch continue
we use an appropriate way to express
some good will
this is my personal understanding based
on my limited professional background
if we understand the matter for the
perspective of the international
political economy i think there's a
tactical and political value in it
opening the financial markets between
china united states itself
right you hold on united states don't
dump me in that case
can you understand it that way yeah i
understand it the other way around
which has happened i happen to think
that this could be another explosive
theory i have to think that opening the
financial markets
is precisely the sort of decoupling of
the united states
opening up the financial markets and
that's exactly what decomposition
is in a sense why are we given such a
hard time in many of these
does he get into what i want you to put
up or no
okay so so this is something you have to
watch on your own because
there's a part where he talks about
saying we have people on the inside and
wall street we have people on the inside
on politics he says we have people on
the inside all the way at the top of the
u.s government
china does yeah we have people on the
inside at the top of the u.s government
china does right
then so whilst then he says trump was a
problem for them
trump got in the way for them trump
didn't help him out but biden's easy to
deal with
biden's gonna be easier to deal with
because we're back to being able to do
what we wanted to do all these years
here's the problem let me give you the
problem here he validated
what happened with biden and who helped
him out this guy's validated it
that that took place and
there was relations between biden and
and what he called it uh
china and this one hunter and biden of
course
biden and china hunter biden's not doing
anything with china without joe biden
hunter biden cannot do anything in china
without his father joe biden
and he said that in interviews hunter
biden asked the question but one
one interviewer asked biden a question
saying do you think
you would have been able to get this
board seat without your father hunter
biden's answer this isn't a live
interview you know what he says
probably not without my father hunter
biden said this in an interview okay
where am i going with this here's where
i'm going with this let's just say
china has a million and one different
dirt on biden let's just say they do
let's assume they do let's play that
card
if china has a lot of dirt on biden
if they do how do you negotiate with
biden
you use it against them actually think
about what i just said right there
if china who is growing the way they're
growing right now
and they're about do you need water or
you're good and they're about to be the
number one
gdp economy in the world their military
is
ridiculously grown for the longest time
they kept saying we're not military
we're not military we're not military
now they're investing into their
military they're gene testing their
soldiers
they have the biggest navy okay they're
doing all the stuff that they're doing
over there they're the best at bio
warfare
they're the best at cyber warfare
they're the best at it they're going in
that direction
what happens if china has all the dirt
on biden
so imagine behind closed doors how do
negotiations go how do you negotiate
with them
what do you say simplify what do you say
hey
you know i just want you to know you
know i interviewed this guy from the fbi
what was his name uh uh whitehurst is it
whitehurst
okay so this is the only guy in the fbi
that ever sued the fbi and got a 1.4
million dollar check the only employee
in the history of fbi that sued the fbi
and president clinton and got a 1.4
million dollar check in 1993.
he's the only guy that's ever done it
successfully okay and he got ousted
i said the who's the most powerful
person in politics john f kennedy
remember when a question i asked him
john f kennedy
uh uh edgar who j edgar hoover or uh the
mafia he says oh j edgar hoover
he says fbi is the most powerful
organization in america
more than the president so really yeah i
said how do they do it he says here's
how we do it
he says you're going you just say look
you know
like you know you got to do this you
know
you know you know what i mean you know
don't even have to say it
you got to do this you know what i'm
saying so he says that's all we say
and they know and they have to do
exactly what we want them to do because
they know
we know you think china's going to use
that card against biden behind closers
saying hey joe
you know we know so we kind of need you
to
sure do this do you think that's what's
going to happen i i think it's already
happening probably with how we stack in
his cabinet
with a little help from you you have to
keep that part in mind man this is the
kind of stuff because now here's the
other part
you know what's the other part um
how long does it take you to do research
on somebody online who's pretty active
on social media to know which way they
lean politically
how much time not 10 minutes i'm being
serious with everybody here
not long how long will it take you to
research somebody online
it could be a minute could be a minute
okay i agree with you could be a minute
okay fair enough
how much can you learn about anybody if
you know their enemy
i mean you can learn a lot what can you
learn about them how long can you learn
about anybody
if you can learn who their number one
enemy is
i see we're going with this okay so
where am i going with this here's where
i'm going with this
in the next 3 6 12 months you know what
mainstream media
i project predict is going to do here's
what they're going to do
mainstream media is about to sell
us who the real enemy is over the next
four years under biden administration
and i don't think they're going to sell
china for being the number one enemy
i think they're going to make russia the
number one enemy
potentially iran which iran is an enemy
i don't know if they're number one in it
because iran reports to who
to china okay don't forget that
china is bailing out iran china's
investing into iran which means iran
owes
who china a favor okay
china's plain africa china is playing
everybody right now is what they're
doing
because they have money they're playing
everybody right now
media is going to try to sell us that
somebody else is the enemy russia is not
a top 10 economy
russia is not a top 10 economy if you
you just saw the list right there
yeah it's not going to be any of those
guys china
is ahead so far it's not even
funny what they can do today and this is
just
getting started they're just getting
warmed up
the momentum that was going on when
people say why are you
supporting the trump this and trump that
i said dude i don't
support a trump does trump that what i
supported was one thing
i wanted to see how china was going to
react if we went with the sanctions
and the terrorists for four more years i
wanted to see what was going to
happen to iran if you went with the
sanctions and the terrorists for a
couple more years
that's what i wanted to see because
there's one person they couldn't
negotiate with
and it was trump they couldn't buy him
out he wasn't he was the one guy they
couldn't buy out
now i hope i'm 100 wrong
mm-hmm i hope i'm 100 wrong i hope i'm
100
wrong about all of this but if i'm not
china is going to make a lot of
advancement the next four years because
they're going to be able to ask
and say hey joe just so you know you
know we know right yes
we need you to put this person on your
administration joe you know we know
right we need this person to get a job
at fbi
hey you know we know right this person
what do you think they know what do i
think they know
yeah what do you mean what do i think
they know if
they have done all the business dealings
with china if they have done all the
business dealings with china the biden
family
guess what they know all the business
dealings they did with china
that would have hurt him in the election
and they can say we will release
everything and ruin your life and if you
don't think we know more we know
everything about your son
you know what happened the other day
facebook got caught did you guys hear
about what facebook got caught with okay
okay just type in on google facebook
camera instagram you guys hear about
this or no
yeah a little bit okay facebook
instagram camera
okay facebook instagram camera
okay just this should be a couple days
ago and go to news
go to news
we're looking at fresh nature's lawsuit
from 40 different states
okay a story came out facebook there you
go bloomberg
okay this is not just any side facebook
accused of watching
instagram users through cameras to learn
more about them by the way this got even
deeper
in the last few days read the story
though so facebook is being sued again
uh for allegedly spying on instagram
users this time through unauthorized use
of their mobile phone cameras
so think about this you're sitting in
the bathroom you're on your instagram
again you're checking everybody else's
picture they're watching you
you're laying next to your girl you're
laying in bed next to your girl
and you're on your instagram and you're
showing her a picture they're watching
you
okay you know what they said oh was a
glitch it wasn't it wasn't intentional
was accidental
that this happened okay you know i used
to be the guy that would be like oh come
on guys when people put a sticker over
here on the camera you know which camera
i'm telling everybody would you remember
when apple back in the days they would
play put the sticker over there people
are watching like dude are you freaking
out of your mind
i'd be the first one to say what is
wrong with you you know
lawsuit bloomberg this is not an opinion
this is lawsuit bloomberg right
okay this stuff is happening a lot of
these conspiracy theories that we
thought were conspiracy theories are now
becoming conspiracy theories they're
becoming factual wow
so with china has access to the best
hackers in the world
what do you think they have on their
cameras
what do they have access on their
cameras do you think they can tap into
hunter biden who's constantly losing his
laptops left and right leaving them
behind
what do you think you have access to let
me tell you when j edgar hoover would go
and talk to john f kennedy and bobby and
would say hey
we just want you know this is what we
got and a mafia
who had control over hoover they went to
hoover and they said
hey we know you're a cross-dresser
because back in the days that was a big
deal for
j it's not today's times we're talking
about years ago
they say here's what we know you do j
grover if you ever talk about the mafia
we're gonna have a problem
so back then they played the same game
hoover played against kennedy the ma
played against two
hoover hoover yeah china's about to play
that card against biden if they do
buddy this isn't about you and i anymore
this is about fundamentally what they're
gonna try to do to the idea of america
because there are some
china is one of the most competitive
groups of people
and they want to beat the number one
country in the last 150 years
and that's u.s yep and they're all i
want to beat them they're also patient
and they're also strategic
and they also have the media on their
side here because cnn has already come
out and said that they ignored the
hunter biden story
which goes along the lines of i honestly
think and adam's going to jump all over
me again i don't think joe biden wanted
to win this election
personally because i think he's smart
enough to know what's out there
what can be revealed in all this and
that's why i think he'll kind of
fade away but you know the difference
between china and the u.s
again is we think the our enemy is the
other side
you know the republicans think the enemy
is the left the left thinks the enemy is
the right we spend
50 percent of our time fighting amongst
ourselves when we should be putting
all our time into looking what's
happening at the people that really do
hate us
and do want to take what we have and do
want to change us and that is going to
be our undoing and it's starting to
happen
and then when you have a complicit media
and a complicit social media
and especially something that can be
manipulated by our real enemies we've
got real problems
obviously i i think joe biden wanted to
win i don't think you'd do all this
to not win um you know ironically you
use joe biden's
go-to quote that we are not the enemies
of each other we need to come together
whether you're on the left or the right
we're all americans that whole thing
blue state red state
clearly china's a major issue clearly uh
if they truly did and i'm not saying
that they don't i'm
i'm asking a question here if they truly
did have something on him
why would he run meaning he has to know
like as much as you want to say wait
what wait wait wait
okay wait okay he did something illegal
yeah if he did something
then you missed everything i just said
that's not obviously i heard everything
you missed everything i just said
okay what did i mention so ask the
question again why would he run
why would he run okay did you just miss
everything i just said no
pat but ask yourself you're saying that
he's a pawn for trump
wait a minute if you're saying why would
he run if they know everything you know
because
you're saying he's a pawn for china
because they can tell you
you better run don't worry you will win
look we're at a point right now is it
fair to say that
is it fair to say that i'm going deeper
no i'm not going deep with this
is it fair to say at this point of the
game is it fair to say that america has
meddled in a lot of other countries
elections
they say that yes or no they say that
there we can't sit here and be like i'm
not sitting here being naive and a fool
about it
there's proof that there's been
america's meddled in other countries
elections
okay because america said i think that's
a good the reason why other countries
cannot stand america sometimes is why
power because we've meddled because we
meddled okay do you think russia has
meddled in other people's elections for
sure do you think china's meddled on
other people's elections
do you think iran's meddled in other
people's elections quite frankly
what's the theme here what are you doing
what do you need to meddle in other
people's elections
actually what ability do you need it's
one ability what is the information
in formation and propaganda and hackers
yeah
you need you need proper hackers and
proper digital marketing guys these days
yeah i mean prior to you know 2000 that
was not
but there was a different method of
doing it back then today it's a lot
easier today
you need some 22 year old kids who
understand facebook codes you need some
guys who are 18 year old kids behind
closers who know how to hack into the
pentagon system
it's not that complicated for these guys
it's very easy for them
very easy you know how you play
basketball and you effortless and all
this stuff you do it's very easy for
them effortless they can hack into any
system they want
it's easy for them so when you say if
this is the case why would biden want to
run you miss
everything i just said they would want
if you if you're china think like china
think like the enemy
actually think like the enemy let's
think like the enemy
you're china it's 2018.
this crazy competitive guy who's not
afraid of you
says i'm putting tariffs on you
this this guy that says if you don't do
xyz i'm putting sanctions
this guy out of nowhere comes out and
says wait a minute
you had huawei cfo daughter in canada
doing deals with iran and i told you not
to do business with anyone
with uh what do you call it iran why
would you decide to do that the cfo the
daughter she gets arrested no problem
sanctions on huawei sanctions on china
sanctions on iran
and if anybody does business with iran
you can't do anything with u.s
22 countries or give or take say iran we
can't do any business with you
iran takes a massive gas prices go up
government of iran says for one day gas
price is going to be this much just
protesting in the series because iranian
cannot drive
we have to do what we have to do you
know how hated trump was for what he did
so now you're china and we're the enemy
the three of us are representing china
imagine we're on china's board the three
of us we're strategic no one knows about
us we're behind a closed type of
speakers
we don't want any attention we're
strategists
how do you what list think think
like you're china and you're behind
closed doors how do you take down
america to become number one
who's the number one enemy you have now
that you got to get rid of
trump how do you get rid of them we know
how to do it
how do we get rid of them who owes us
the most favors
who do we have the most dirt on biden
there you go buddy
it's not just biting but it's a list of
people he's one of them
but you go from the top and you work
your way down and typically you need to
have the people at the top
that owe you the biggest favors who has
the most influence because that's the
easiest ones to go through
by the way you sit there and you're
thinking like i think i want to be right
i'm hoping i'm 100 wrong i don't think
i'm wrong
i'm hoping i'm 100 wrong but this is the
dirty part about politics that you deal
with this
so you think from
2019 beyond even by because biden was
considering running
in 2016. when
hillary kind of boxed them out at that
point yeah he was thinking about
running back then okay um huh
timing wasn't good for him but yeah but
there's there's conversation behind
closers where obama's won and sat down
with biden said it's clinton's turn
you can run next but right now let's so
in those four years
yeah before he ran yup you're saying
that's when the shady dealings
likely occurred no that's not what i'm
saying the shady dealing's been going on
for a while
even while he was vice president what
are you talking about
that's the whole thing with hunter what
was caught as he was getting favors when
biden was the vp
i thought a lot of that was in ukraine
china as well you're saying
of course hunter was taking advantage of
his last name
being biden yeah but but this is this is
the this is the part so if he's fearful
of these stories being leaked
like we're leaking it right now
right now people people are talking
we're talking no but there's a big
you're saying that the there's a
mainstream media there's a big
difference between
you saying i think johnny
hooked up with mary versus mary coming
out and saying
he hooked up with me gotcha okay mary is
china the smoking gun
yeah mary's china mary's gonna come out
and say he did hook up with us
and if biden would have let's say
hypothetically
lost right like because biden would have
to get back to 2019 he didn't win iowa
he didn't win new hampshire trump's next
four
years would have been a uh joke compared
to the first four years meaning it would
have been the hardest four years of his
life
if trump would have won it would have
been the hardest four years of trump's
meaning if there was a different
candidate bernie sanders would have been
the candidate if
okay that's my point is that you're
saying that china china didn't want
bernie sanders
china doesn't want to elizabeth warner p
buddha these are nobodies
to them china wants hillary china wants
biden
china wants uh huh they want the
political league they don't want any of
these others
can you imagine what an easy mark hunter
biden was for china
i mean a guy that just is morally
compromised where you could just throw
easy money at him
and you own them because you would think
at some point hunter biden would think
man this is a little bit too good to be
true these boards really want me sitting
you know on them and collecting this
type of check there has to be something
else
involved it's it's unbelievable how much
info they probably have on him
played right into it look yeah stuff man
yeah it's
it's uh it's the the stories are this is
nothing new
churchill was the most hated guy in
uk but even the people
at the top who hated churchill knew
there was only one guy that could go up
against
hitler it was only churchill let me say
that one more time yeah
churchill was hated he was hated
tremendously
he was an obnoxious guy he was annoying
he was trump's times a hundred
you have to realize churchill was a true
believer at the highest level
the stuff that this guy did at a young
age how many books did he write how many
think
the things churchill accomplished in his
lifetime there's a very few people that
are at his level by the way
very few people and he was cocky he was
arrogant he was confident he was
every single word about an annoying
person you can put up
churchill was trump times 10 is who
churchill was
but they knew only one guy could go up
against hitler and it was him and what
happened
save the country we'd be talking german
right now you and i
our language will be german right now
cassie schutz on that whole crew exactly
that's the point we we the germans
you know they would be ruling the world
today if it wasn't for god like
churchill so
you have to be very careful with
personalities like him
like a trump you have to be very careful
with personalities like him
to not emotionally dislike her it's such
a hard yesterday i'm doing an interview
with this girl drop that gorgeous girl
who's trying to introduce her to you
like this is a girl you guys
hooked me up no she had a boyfriend
already i'm like dude i want to
introduce her to you
so she's interviewing me i think she's
out of canada toronto
i think her name is marianna or
something like that right
and she's interviewing me and she asks a
question she says
she says how do you make your decisions
with uh
being able to be reasonable without
letting your emotions get involved
number one question i asked you what she
teed you up right into your wheelchair
i thought like she had talked to you or
something like do you hang out with adam
obviously not but so
so so she says this question i'm like
okay it is very like for me
listen i did not like when obama came
out with obamacare
i didn't like it the reason why i didn't
like it because it was forced if we
would have waited a year later
we could have possibly had both sides
and had a different kind of a program it
was forced
let's get it through let's get it
through it's not going to be taxed and
all of a sudden health insurance
industry gone
my insurance for the employees went up
to the roof 40 one year 40
next year 40 next i'm like dude this is
ridiculous what we have to pay to
employees
but i won't sit there and say obama
doesn't
know how to play the game of politics i
wouldn't say
obama's not suave i can set aside
policies versus personality
trump's personality can be annoying
trump's personality can be very
frustrating trump's personality can be
unattractive this guy thinks he's better
than you in everything he does in his
life
if trump played you in basketball he
would probably think he's better than
you he probably thinks he's going to be
better than you matt
that's trump's mindset it's unattractive
to a lot of people
on the opposite side right but at the
same time
you want somebody going up against china
who do you want going up against china
if you got the number one enemy in the
world being china who do you want going
up against them
what kind of a personality do you want
going up against them somebody that
china fears or somebody that china
thinks they can get anything out of that
that's strategic questions you
you know those are things that you have
to sit there and think about and say
well you know
i don't know you know i may want to have
this guy go out there and sit down and
have those conversations with me
anyways what do you think they're
gearing up their military for japan
oh own just owning that part of the
globe they're coming all over
the south china sea is obviously a big
thing that they're concerned about
building
i think they've built the island listen
why do you buy life insurance policy
because you're planning on killing
yourself next day
no why do we buy auto insurance because
we're trying to kill our you know go
into a car accident next day
interesting there is just a just in case
it is just to tell you okay
come on come on come on you want to go
let's go
come on u.s come on see what we got see
what we got
test us and see what's going to take
place very big yesterday i interviewed
saddam hussein's sons double
they died july 22nd of 03 they died so
they died three years before saddam got
killed in december vote six so
but anyway so i'm interviewing uh the
scanning latif
whose day is double okay and you're
sitting there hearing the stories
of how they play these games oh my gosh
it is a dirty game how these guys play
these games but half the battle is what
you better know what i'm capable of
china is trying to tell the world
try us try us in cyber warfare try us in
biowarfare
try us in direct warfare try us an
innovation
try us in technology try us and
manufacture and try us
they want the monopoly they want it all
they want it all and they got a
nearly a couple billion people of
inventory to be dealing with fyi when
you're talking about a company company
country
quoting joe biden we are we're so
focused on fighting
with each other that we're missing
really who the true enemy is and and
china's just sitting there just yeah
excuse me is there any solace in knowing
we can beat them in basketball
i actually don't think that's even going
to happen i think even basketball china
is going to
great oh not in the game of basketball
but i think controlling the nba
that's right not in the game of
basketball i think china
knows because look lebron just got paid
what two years 85 million
you know what happens if nba was being
played in china every day you know what
his salary would have been it would have
been two years 200 million
lebron would have been 100. if howard
stern's making 100 million dollar
contract for seven years they're about
to sign about 60 some years old
you don't think lebron's worth 100
million dollars well yes if we're in
china
yeah can you imagine if they say we're
in china now next superstar is coming up
they're getting a ten year billion
dollar contract yes if you're in china
that would happen
so imagine behind closed doors adam
silver and these nba owners are saying
guys you know when it comes down to
china let's not talk a lot of smack
about china because
you could be the first to get a
billionaire i'm actually being dead
seriously you know that so you got that
big of a mark you saw what happened with
daryl mori and the houston rockets and
there you go exactly and hard and still
didn't show up to yesterday to practice
about that he's holding out so you guys
got if you if you
for one second underestimate the power
of china you are naive